nein da hab ich habe ein krisenteam
geschleudert ist gestorben
das werde ich dir etwas intro wagen war
der killer roboter um sind 2
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer und konnte
vp schau mal wieder mein tor
hier sind schon wieder leute neben mir
und schlagen um mich rum also das video
hat nahezu gar nichts gebracht was wir
gemacht haben aber naja wir schauen
einfach mal wieder im spiel wird mein
wasser mittlerweile der einzige motor
das geht in einer sekunde los die man
spielen kann ohne dass man bei ingram
gekeltert ich habe mich meine sache
bekommen
ich habe zwar später welches team bist
du immer wir sind ein team das ist gut
so gut es ist mir also wie wir spielen
auch heute nur eine runde und ich habe
keine fans kam und man hat keine
festplatte festgemacht heuer doch haben
es relativ schnell bei ihm haben bei
sehr sehr wenig zeit haben brustpanzer
für dich wenn du willst
oh ja das wär da ist die warteliste da
hinein ins klo karadzic okay das war's
dann bleiben ihr wisst ihr ich einfach
zusammenbleiben
wir brauchen das ok heute nur eine runde
weil ich habe wenig zeit und wir wollten
jetzt eben noch was aufnehmen damit er
nicht wieder keine runde hat mit unserem
kreis immer zusammen alleine trends
zeitung
hier sind auch floridas in hellblau das
ganz alleine das ganz alleine drauf da
drauf da müssen wir versuchen unsere
leben zu behalten und ihre leben runter
zu
er wollte und wie geht das gut
sie wollten hier oder und so getroffen
einmal etwas wissen wird deckung gehen
wo ich mag nein ich war oben und war
arbeitet hat schon wieder einen bogen
aber ich hab dich auch wieder alle
geschichten weg ist neckermann den
quartal ist vorgeschrieben so mehr tut
ist desto mehr hast du dann wenn du neue
sports wie der so mehr hat man bei 6 in
folge tschechen die aber ein schwert
oder sowas
dass bald die ganze zeit ich hab da
jetzt mal krass viel miteinander
getöteten gold wert ich habe jetzt auch
nur ein bogen unten goldstädter total
bilder tonne weisgemacht erfreut ich hab
keine sachen hast du irgendwelche sachen
für mich irgendwas egal wer da kommt ja
okay bin hab ich habe schon bekommen ins
knie ich bin da ist sie bekommen was
jetzt schon irgendwelche sachen bekommen
sie so wollen wir feiern würden dann
bitte ganz kurz an davon muss ich ein
foto machen
du bist voll mit pfeilen etwa nur wenn
man stehen und mit dem krieg gemacht
foto verraucht ist immer schön zu damit
eine sache bleiben geht darum ich
gefragt ob jemand beschwert hat
vorsichtig woche deckung ja weg trotzdem
muss doch irgendwo noch eine kiste sein
möchte einfach nur schwer hat hci
odenkirchen euch auf dem stein steht
jetzt cool du bist du bist du in dem
haus programm anfang waren lass uns
treffen dann [ __ ] okay okay ich bin
ich bin hier in ihre kassen creeper das
ist mein quartier unterwegs
ich hoffe wir jetzt eine von unseren
leuten krieg nennen weil folta sein job
geht
nein da killer ich hab den kripobeamten
geschleudert jetzt gestorben doch das
war ja das werde ich dir etwas intro
warten war der killer oliver darum sind
29 cent wir gehen gut abwägen ab was
sind eigentlich die nacht ist wir sind
team love is ja
ich muss im schwerter wiederkommen
schalter doch wer wacht leben nachtleben
diamant hat noch viele waren auch mehr
als ihr alter warum steht er ja nicht
ich hab dich geschlagen
der blog ich gemacht hab es spielt
geschickt
ok go ist klappt es wird knapp es ein
knappes gut ab oh oh
haben wir denn wir haben ja so viel sex
leben gott oh gott oh gott da oben
liegen richtig viele items also nur
items raus ich habe ich alles außer
teile ich habe alles okay dann würde ich
sagen bleiben erst mal ganz kurz hier
oben also entweder das auch gemacht dann
kam mir immer leute hoch darum kommt da
kommt jetzt mit zwei drei leute beide
todt beide tot
doch perfekt effektiv einrücken
abgerissen okay das auto zurück ja
wieder hoch wieder hoch oder fünf leben
komm hoch sie mal einen richtigen
richtung
ich habe mein schwert dass ich jetzt
erst recht weil ich die alle getötet
habe oder wie jetzt
ok junge ist richtig den nahkampf müssen
jetzt richtig durch diesen schritt von
der schweiz gleich weiß nicht wie viel
wir haben die absicht auch zwei
lebewesen sind so gut aus wir sind in
love is all den mache ich noch getötet
wir haben jetzt hängt einmal rein hier
ihr können am nächsten leben hat bleibt
lesen doch wir sind auf dem laub ist ein
diamant auch noch 20
ja nein ich bin raus ich kann nicht mehr
sieben und ich kann man scheiße
er ist okay leute hatten jetzt halt ein
mal in folge die unter zehn oder 15
minuten alt ist ist jetzt ja auch nicht
so schlimm morgen bekommt ihr dafür
wieder eine folge morgen abend dann auch
mit facebook ist wahrscheinlich und dann
würde ich sagen es euch gefallen hat
dürft ihr gerne eine positive bewertung
abgeben und uns weitere spielmodi in die
kommentare schreiben
eventuell auch welche die man einerseits
auf servern spielen kann und
andererseits auch die nicht so verbuggt
sind wie trouble im einzel oder so ja
und dann sagen wir ja wenn ihr bisschen
vorstellst unsere zeit probleme und
hab's dann zeigen wir euch auf jeden
fall also nimmst du uns ist nicht übel
und wie ihr seht kommt dass im supercopa
h bis zum nächsten mal leute schau schau